Aaron Sampson here with Ryan Schubert
and today we're going to talk about
going to the moon to find moon wizards
moon wizards yes yes if you blinked on
Saturday you probably missed the moon
mission which came up for a bout two
hours I did in fact blink and miss it it
was one of the timed events in the
destiny beta along with some of the iron
banner multiplayer missions will get to
multiplayer in a minute but the first
thing we're going to do is talk about
this moon mission while we're just sort
of talking about our general impressions
of the destiny beta overall we gave up
the moon to keep the hive away from
early we hope that would be enough for
them
I used to look up here at night and
wonder what the hive were doing but the
only activity i could ever pick up was
hazy like it was blocked for buried
so we're going to focus on a little bit
of constructive criticism for the
destiny beta you know overall this game
is extremely well polished graphically
and the sound i think is fantastic i
love the sound design and 3d directional
sound design oh yeah and that extending
to even a online chat where you could be
you know you're the people that you're
playing with when they talk / chat like
you can hear them talking behind you or
to the side and there's voice effects
that like take on the shape of the room
like it's a big room it'll echo or if
it's a cavern it'll like sound like it's
coming from that kind of place so the
the issue that i have with destiny and i
think this is something that Bungie is
going to have a little bit of time to
work on is I feel like underneath all
this polish they haven't quite worked
out their gameplay mechanics you know
enough yet I feel like a lot of the
things in this game that you see have
just been done by either borderlands or
defiance two games specifically and have
been done you know a little bit better
than some of these these mechanics that
we're seeing in this game so the first
thing we're gonna talk about and just so
that were clear that's not to say that
this is done poorly yeah it's just if
you're gonna if you're going to go back
over territory like you just have to
learn from your forebears and then
improve on that formula that's a that's
definitely a stand on the shoulders of
giants type of thing of you know some
things have just been done to a level
that's so good that there's no reason to
not go to that level again mmm and then
just take it a notch further so the
first thing that you and I were talking
about mostly was the classes we would
really like to see bungee make the
classes have much more significant
differences than they have in this beta
yeah I mean I would I want to give
bungee the benefit of the doubt and say
that we can chalk this up to a capping
out at eight but you know the thing
about that was that you know when you
create that character at the beginning
when you vary when you start the game it
teases you with the knowledge of a sort
of an idea of what level 15 is going to
be and it seems like if these classes
don't really come into their
own until well past the level cap in the
beta and so I what I'm hoping is that we
just didn't get enough of a glimpse of
the distinction moving forward so you
played all three classes give me a quick
breakdown of your impressions of each
class and how they're different um so
that's sort of my problem is that I had
a lot of trouble differentiating the
classes while I was playing them I mean
yes as you progress you unlock certain
very specific special abilities but
there wasn't something that separated
them so much to me that I felt like you
know if I was going on a mission I would
think man I really need a diverse party
because you know you need somebody who
can throw status effects you need
somebody who's a shooter you need
somebody who's a an engineer or
something like it didn't have a class
distinction Ernest necessity to class
distinction and you told me you sort of
came to this discovery through melee
combat right that was one of the first
thing that was the first thing so the
first thing I did was create a hunter
and I would I you know I got I loved
playing you know like melee combat
characters in these types of games I
played 0 and borderlands and I was
thinking okay I'm gonna go that route
I'm going to be a hand-to-hand beast and
I'm gonna carry a sniper rifle for all
other circumstances and I totally played
that way and totally enjoyed it and then
a few days later I went back you know
after i capped out at eight I went back
and created a Titan and I thought okay
I'm gonna now i'm going to create a
character that's a machine gunning
vicious angry robot sob and on my first
playthrough of just the very beginning
of the game i found myself running up
face to face two enemies and attacking
them with melee and not noticing that
there was really any appreciable
difference between that and my
experience with the hunter and I thought
okay well so this is also a good
character for Maylee and then a little
while later i'm looking at my character
model and realizing that's the exact
same almost the exact same model as zero
from Borderlands and I thought oh well
maybe I got it wrong maybe the hunter
isn't precisely that character maybe the
Titan is and it's just a little
different and then a couple days later I
go back and I make a
a lot and that is where I started
getting confused because all of a sudden
especially once you level up to like
three or four with the Warlock your
melee ability is actually more powerful
than any of the other ones and I
couldn't wrap my mind around how the
hunter which I would think would be like
an assassin character the Titan which is
a soldier how each of those would have a
weaker male II than the wizard yet mean
it's interesting it feels like
oftentimes Destiny's trying to ride this
line between being a shooter and being
an MMO but the thing is if you're gonna
be an MMO you have to sort of live
within the MMO conventions and typically
a hunter within an MMO their powers come
from rooting enemies in place attacking
them with familiars sniping it range I
mean that's traditionally what's
associated with a hunter and if you're
not going to do that then you have to
you know you have to significantly alter
the hunter formula while retaining
people's notion of what that identity is
yeah i mean i don't think and I don't
think you're trying to say this I don't
think you have to be like adhere to
convention so much as at least have
convention you have to understand the
convention I don't break it Yeah right
so you have to acknowledge the
convention in order to break the
convention in a way that's hopefully
better than what it is in the first
place right so I played as the Warlock
the entire beta and I you know I enjoyed
the class as it was it was really good
at you know running in killing things
especially with with head shots with the
hand cannon you know dropping a lot of
damage than retreating and using armor
bonuses to sort of get your vortex back
up and running again or one of the
unlocks allowed your your palm strike or
whatever that thing is called to
basically also help recharge your vortex
grenade but again like it felt like like
as a wizard I should have been doing
more you know I like I don't feel like
the vortex grenade it should have been
so much just like every other grenade in
the game like I'm a wizard like I should
be doing more magic kind of stuff right
and you know like so like later on you
can get the blink ability rather than
the double jump
but I don't know if you are starting off
as the Warlock it feels like they could
have already had initial differences by
giving you the blank to start off with
where you know something to that effect
and more like maybe having their melee
attack be I don't know like a wizard
blowtorch or something yes you know and
as I progressed through the wizard treat
another thing I noticed was a lot of
times things that I unlocked didn't seem
to make any difference in in my combat
Rogers barona so it would trade some
stats some minor stats that were either
not noticeable or didn't you know like
didn't didn't communicate to you what
they were doing or in the case of the
vortex grenade the scatter grenade
version of it just seemed flat-out less
effective so there was no reason for you
to use it I had the exact same
experience with the hunters grenade
after upgrades to sort of a minefield
using that in PvP was comically
pointless yeah I did I there were a
couple of times where I you know nailed
somebody with a grenade before they
killed me and then I just watched all of
those mines track them and then like
slightly hurt them so overall I think
that what Bungie should do with the
classes after this beta is work very
hard to differentiate them in ways that
are meaningful the players and also
maybe some of that is happening but it's
just not being communicated through the
interface to the players there's I feel
like you're right that there's probably
a little bit more they should do but i
do once again want to give them the
benefit of the doubt that the beta just
doesn't go far enough i'd also like to
see them you know work with the classes
in ways where they interplay with each
other better so their skills complement
one another yes and it's possible like
for example the Warlock had a son singer
sub skill tree that unlocked at 15 so
we're not going to see that till the
full release but it did say and that's
something about buffing character so you
know that's a little bit more
traditional MMO style unlocks so let's
talk about the classes in multiplayer so
there's two types of multiplayer so far
in this beta for limited times iron
banner was open which allowed you to
take the gear
that you had with you and allowed you to
use the stats that are already on that
gear and then there was regular
multiplayer which it indicated through
the description just kind of evened out
all the armor and gear right so the
largest thing with multiplayer was they
need to rebalance the weapons a little
bit so there was pretty much no reason
to not run with an assault rifle and a
shotgun because there was nothing more
effective than those two weapons in
multiplayer that was definitely my
experience I mean I I tried everything
out but um you know the the game mode
and the environments just weren't at
least for me like really conducive to
anything else other than occasionally
getting heavy weapon ammo and shooting
somebody with a rocket or a machine gun
I mean the mood the multiplayer moon
level to me was the most creative level
that they should because it had vehicles
in it and it had reasons to use vehicles
I would have preferred without level was
a little bit larger to encourage sort of
like longer sections of vehicle combat
mm-hmm whereas the exact opposite to
that one of the levels that I wasn't too
keen on was a shores of time which I
thought just kind of had this Swiss
cheese design and there was no
particular rhyme or reason to it there
was just people popping out of every
doorway and just sort of a chaotic and
not really add like a fun conducive team
way yeah you know for a game that shares
with titanfall the like sort of double
jump ability and by the way I noticed
that it's different for every class yeah
and the hunter class had the double jump
most mechanically similar to titanfall
angels been playing titanfall the double
jump would feel exactly the same because
the double jump for the Warlock is
extremely floaty and you actually it
feels like you lose your forward
momentum yeah like you go up instead of
forward yeah it's a warlocks float and I
end the thing to be fair the idea behind
that is it so that you can use your
special attack with more precision but
it's detrimental to your health for sure
in a regular firefight oh yeah you get
anybody can track you and shoot you down
there's nothing left not even the light
where's this goose
you
we may want to move back
anyway going back to the yeah the hunter
is the closest to titanfall I found but
for a game that has double jump across
all three classes that were presented
here in the beta I didn't feel like the
map design really played into that like
you know one of the things we talked
about that we love about titanfall is
that it you know the the freedom of
movement is so liberating and you know
destiny does give you at least that sort
of double jump or rocket jump type of
ability yet there weren't any let me put
this way the moon and the shores of time
maps didn't really provide very much in
the way of taking advantage of that
gameplay style there's maybe a couple
instances where that's not quite true of
the two that showed up in iron banner
the two maps that we didn't see normally
going back real quick the other thing I
forgot to mention why wasn't the
multiplayer mode Kill Confirmed
particularly with the whole ghost
mechanic I'm not even a huge fan of Kill
Confirmed but you know when you're
playing multiplayer you're right
somebody gets killed and their ghost is
left behind and it just seems like
that's an obvious thing to pick up you'd
also mentioned something that I was
thinking about too is that the progress
that you make in PvP was not
significantly better or in many cases
was worse than PvE and I think the charm
of this game was largely in its PvE so I
had a hard time justifying spending my
time in PvP yeah it's it we should not
dwell on PvP okay let's talk about just
the game overall the sort of the writing
in the in the level design mostly in the
environments so one of the issues that I
had and I you know again some is it's
interesting because I think this ties
back into not differentiating between
classes enough is not differentiating
between environments enough so for
example this moon mission the first time
I landed on this moon and realized it
had the same gravity as Earth that
immediately pulled me out of the story
you know it's like it's it just it's
like hey we just changed the Sky box and
some of the terrain and but you're not
on the moon you're you're on earth with
Earth's gravity so you know I and you
know it's the same thing like fighting
the two races like you have the hive
right and you have the Fallen but you
seem you seem to see the same guys over
and over again and all that they've
changes the numbers over their head so I
just I would really really like to see
in the full release of this game she's a
lot more enemy variety and to their
credit we may get that we haven't seen
anything other than oh yeah you know
Russia and the moon and you know the
other criticism that I have is I
wouldn't mind it if they would get Peter
Dinklage back in the studio with a
slight rewrite of his ghost character
and weren't too into the dialogue the
problem with Peter Dinklage's characters
it's not a character so much as just a
call-out mechanic like he just states
what it is that you're seeing at any
given time and it's the you know it's
the old problem with writing like you
know you take a creative writing class
the first thing they tell you is show
people don't tell them and all Peter
Dinklage's character ever does is tell
you what you're already seeing it's
already being shown to you so I mean
unless you know his character surges
like help for people who are visually
impaired which is entirely possible um
he's just saying like hey that
spaceships flying too low to the ground
that's unusual hey this bad guy just
jumped out of a wall you know we're like
even some of his lines that are story
centric for example the beginning of
this mission he says you know oh we left
the hive you know we let the we let the
fall and have the moon in hopes that
they wouldn't come to earth and it's
like did you guys think about that line
before you wrote it you gave a
spacefaring race an unmolested base on
the moon within striking distance of
Earth in your surprise they use it as a
launching pad it's just you know words
mean something and you you know the
writing needs to be punched up for sure
in this game you might talk briefly
about weapons cuz I would love to talk
about weapons why is it the neck weapons
yeah we love weapons we like more
weapons than we saw in this beta
um particularly because well okay so
there's one thing that I think they
should change when yours when you switch
or special weapon to another special
weapon you lose all the ammo yeah I'm
hoping that was just a bug I'm assuming
that's something that they're gonna fix
cuz that was really frustrating so you
know in a game like Borderlands there
they just you know they let you go free
here's all your guns here's the ammo you
have for all your guns go and try to
trust the player to use the right guns
at the right time in this game when you
take away their ammo for switching you
basically are locking them into whatever
their first decision was and then
punishing them for not making the right
decision yeah that that can't have that
can't be on purpose or they can't be
something that they'll continue with in
the future also we saw a very kind of
stock selection of guns so you had your
salt rifle you had your sniper rifle you
had your laser weapon which was kind of
like a long-range laser shotgun you know
you had your shotgun minja you had your
hand cannon the only weapon that I
really enjoyed playing with I gotta say
was the hand cannon um I and cannon was
pretty cool I felt like it was sort of a
fresh take on it because it was
essentially short range sniper rifle
right but the other weapons I felt just
very very standard to me and I would
love to see those weapons punched up in
ways that made them more unique well I'm
definitely hoping to see more variety to
the weapons in terms of like qualitative
differences like I spent a lot of time
comparing stats between weapon pickups I
would get but there wasn't very much
ultimately like aesthetically that was
different and it wasn't until a granted
it was on my first playthrough with the
hunter but it wasn't until really late
in that play through that I got rewarded
a pretty high level pulse rifle and
unfortunately for me the pulse rifle was
my least favorite class but um it was
different color different shape had an
egg cogs go
and was clearly like a more interesting
weapon than anything else I had used and
I'm hoping that was sort of like a
preview of things to come that will see
more sort of attachments more things
that distinguish not just on a stat
level but like an aesthetic level and a
handling level in game in much the same
way that in Borderlands like you could
look at the way a weapon physically
looked and before you even compared the
stats which you would do anyway you
could tell that it had certain things
about it just by looking at it on the
ground just lean on the ground like even
before you compared stats which you
could also do without picking up the
weapon but like you could tell like what
kind of scope it had what kind of ammo
it was likely to fight you could
probably tell kind of ammo is gonna fire
you could tell what the ammo capacity
might be like you knew with them you
probably knew who the manufacturer was
that to even playing the game long
enough and that kind of just recognition
immediate recognition is something I'm
hoping to get out of this game and when
you rolled over little release when you
even when you were in your inventory you
were looking at the stats of weapons and
destiny like what is impact is that
damage and you know it's like these
things weren't very clear when you
rolled over it when you looked at the
level of the weapon you know the
description said the level of the weapon
just determines how high a level of PvE
creatures you can take on because
otherwise you get that immune indicator
popping up constantly so you know you
know if if impact is damaged just call
it damaged so that players can you know
like really compare their rifles so you
know is a level 15 rifle really better
than a level 20 rifle other than just it
can take on things with higher numbers
over their heads these are these are
things that they need to work out in
their interface and just sort of improve
the visibility of these things for
players so they know quickly and they
can move on and you know keep playing
the game like one of the things that I
think probably stuns everybody playing
this game is just that the look of it is
pretty beautiful I mean definitely
reminiscent of other games like if I'd
only take two games and compare it I'd
say you've got a little bit of mass
effect and a little bit of fallout
particularly fallout 3 and all of it
just looks so good like even just being
in the tower and like looking out at the
view I mean I remember one time I was at
the tower and I saw people going out on
the little docking bays for the ships
and just like going into their sitting
stance and looking at the view and I
thought man you can actually do that in
this game it does look that good I think
more than any reason after this beta I
want to play this game at least one time
through is largely for tourism um again
you know I agree I think this game is
gorgeous and i loved it tore this game
um in terms of gameplay mechanics I'm
still you know I still think Borderlands
2 has an edge over this game from what
we've seen so far we'll see what destiny
brings it full release but I look
forward to at least one tourism run at
this game I'm with you on that I
definitely want to travel around and see
the sights in this game even if I
ultimately find something about it
frustrating alright well thanks for
joining us on this look at the secret
wizard from the moon mission that was
open for two hours this saturday and the
destiny beta dusty beta is now over but
you can look forward to the four release
of this game on September ninth alright
thanks for watching well thanks for
listening to our thoughts and we'll see
in old Russia in another month